lately I've been playing and reviewing
popular video games as a service for our
viewers a lot of them are gamers and I
thought you know I'll review video games
right that could help from my latest
review we picked these super popular
Skyrim all the kids are talking about
this game I thought I'd try it out
so here ladies and gentlemen is my
review of Skyrim hey Conan here as you
probably know I don't know much about
video games I don't even particularly
like video games I never play them and
for all those reasons I've decided to
review them and rate them today we're
gonna talk about Skyrim I'm told this is
very popular this is the Elder Scrolls 5
for you guys out there and you are guys
help me do this do you play Skyrim yes I
play a lot of Skyrim ok so we just
started the game it looks like I'm
sitting in a cart going through some
foggy woods this is beautiful
countryside you know what a developer
would make a ski slope here to start off
we're gonna choose a character you can
make your own character so these are all
the different races you can be so Nord
this looks like any douchebag bouncer in
a sentence it's a guy that's told me to
just keep walking oh okay that's a high
elf there's a dark elf
so one elf is high and the other is
depressed I'm gonna be the depressed L
cat man what do they want a cat man why
not I'll be the cat all right so now we
have to choose a name I am a cat more or
less so I want to be mr. buttons I'll
strike fear into the heart citizens of
Skyrim now we got to determine what our
body looks like sex yes
[Laughter]
whatever as layer go with how I really
am
wait do whatever you want okay let's
just get through this what color of dirt
do you want here's a problem already
with this game way too many choices for
a few minutes there we were in a
wonderful new world and now I'm doing my
taxes I color cat-like height this is
madness can we move on let's go we've
got it alright okay so here I am on mr.
button mr. buttons now we're in a town
it's called white run white run that's a
very racist name this is a gated
community in bel-air there's a big wall
around this okay let's go talk to this
yeah is that a woman yeah oh yeah oh my
god it was terrifying wait who's talking
she sounds good she sounds attractive
yes once I've made enough money trading
with the Khajiit caravans I'm going to
buy the bannard mare from hold ah okay I
told them that one day I'd become the
best trader in Skyrim she's hot and
she's an earner he said he'd help me get
started if I can bring him a mammoth
tusk
I got a mammoth chest
I could teach you a thing or two about
trading we just have to bring her a
mammoth tusk you know what I'm loving
right now the uncomfortable awkward
pauses this is me in like junior year
like she's waiting for me to say
something clever and I'm not coming up
with anything the girl behind you is
noticing this guy's got no game just
been waiting for me to say something
clever
I got nothing all right red button this
walking around thing has got to stop
don't ye like kill this guy watch this
then I you know no no the wrong thing
turn around there now hits the voice the
top one the top one just hit it with the
mace the right triggers that auto lift
you know the killer I knew okay they
kill you they got really angry you don't
want to do I'm just realizing my mistake
is that I attack warriors right and they
killed me very quickly I want to go to
like a farm and just attack people
without weapons I want to just like kill
some chickens and stuff they don't know
what's coming right now I've got the
mace of gam dal Molag Bal really you had
to correct me oh this is a chicken
let's get these chickens huh
run away oh wait wait letting me oh it's
that guy oh no it's a card turn to the
left to the left
I killed you what pickup me I stared a
chicken I just deserve to die my path I
admit it was a little bit Dicky but I
don't kill anybody
I have an idea alright much easier way
easier right I'm now have a lot of skill
and everyone else is stupid the red
button
I want to successfully do battle with
somebody's there another chicken I can
fight
you might want to go get coffee this is
gonna be a while okay I'm gonna try and
win the girl over by getting a mammoth
tusk
so I'm proceeding to a place where they
have mammoths and what does that thing
oh that's the mammoths nice oh here let
me give you more health real quick you
just help me fight this mammoth you're
the ultimate wingman if you get me this
mammoth tusk we're on the wrong side of
this thing it's got giant pastas always
attack these things from the ass
mcgillich alright get the toss-up now no
thank you
hey all right how do we get back to the
hot girl who wants the mammoth all right
here's one plaque and tusk is that her
there's a haggis though I don't want to
run in like I think that's her yeah hey
hey yeah there you go what here's your
mammoth tusk hey thank you
this should turn that old cat's gaze
maybe I'll be able to become a caravan
ear myself one day thank you
as promised let me show you a thing or
two about bargaining don't want some
shifty merchants giving you a raw trade
fast-forward my relationship is perfect
it's like a girl that I've taken out to
dinner 15 times to good restaurants and
I'm still getting a thanks for the lift
and a peck on the cheek no farewell
you took my time you've got my touch
well now he's talking to me oh great
kill him just kill him okay
bounine tell us what did you think this
guy I'm kind of positive about Skyrim
out of a scale of one to 166 166 being
fairly average one being fairly average
and any 180s being fairly average 17
being really good and then attaching
Roman numerals I would give this a 44 X
X X IV IV
thanks a lot Skyrim you excuse me I'm
gonna go kill some more chickens and
maybe set a butterfly on fire
[Music]